pues me invitaron a dar esta charla ted
y siento que tengo un montón de cosas
que decirles y muy poco tiempo para
hacerlo y en varias ocasiones he tenido
la oportunidad de a través de foros de
conferencias de vídeos compartirles lo
que he hecho y yo creo que venir les a
compartir a platicar una experiencia
personal el día de hoy es una
distracción de lo que realmente importa
ideas problemas y cómo resolverlos
voy a platicarles sobre política y cómo
involucrarse en ella haciendo las cosas
al revés a veces puede tener resultados
sorprendentemente positivos
la política suele ser su ingeniería y
está rodeada de adjetivos negativos que
no necesariamente representan lo que
realmente significa por ejemplo el que
está en el día de hoy ustedes sentados
aquí y a lo largo de esta mañana vayan a
escuchar una serie de historias
inspiradoras o el hecho de que un grupo
de personas maravillosas hayan
organizado este evento para ustedes y
para la ciudad eso
esto es hacer política y al igual que
ellas y ellos necesitamos reivindicar la
urge reivindicar la política
hace un año un grupo de personas nos
planteamos la idea de
construir una candidatura independiente
autogestiva y reivindicar la política
electoral local como algunos de ustedes
recuerdan o ya lo saben fui candidato
independiente en las pasadas elecciones
y el candidato independiente más joven
en la historia de baja california sur
forme parte de la única candidatura
mixta en las elecciones locales
caminamos más de 600 kilómetros en esta
campaña lo que equivale a ir de la paz a
los cabos de ida y vuelta dos veces a
pie
tocamos la puerta de más de 3000 casas y
construimos una candidatura como siempre
habíamos querido que otras personas lo
hicieran
que logramos
primero que nada es importante recalcar
que en grupo de personas que jamás
habían involucrado en una política
electoral que no son militantes que no
tenían experiencia
y que no tienen una plataforma logramos
poner en la boleta a una persona común y
corriente hicimos historia para nosotras
mismas pusimos en la boleta a una
pianista
a un médico
el ciclista a una maestra
hicimos una campaña extremadamente
barata austera sin derrochar dinero sin
padrinos políticos autogestiva y
creativa porque con nuestras propias
manos hicimos nuestra publicidad en ese
sentido en nuestra campaña pues fue
responsable con el medio ambiente porque
en primera logramos suplir los folletos
que todos los días en campaña fuimos
encontrando tirados en la calle
apostando lea
aposté del regionalismo sudcaliforniano
entregar no les sea la mano una postal
en vez de basura
y logramos suplantar también una
logramos suplantar la contaminación
visual que son las zonas que vemos todo
el tiempo que duran las campañas y que
no son reciclables a pesar de que tengan
el ojito y de que son retornables y
hicimos hicimos nuestra publicidad como
decía hace rato con nuestras propias
manos los primos con material reciclado
con cartón
ahora ahora todos los que conozco me
dicen
hay que echarle ganas hay que volver a
intentar
tú puedes que sigue que sigue sin
cumplir nuestra palabra y volver a la
calle
a lo largo de los 11 meses que duró esta
campaña nos dimos cuenta que existe una
infinidad de historias de terror a lo
largo del distrito 2 tan solo a 6
cuadras de aquí del teatro juárez hay un
grupo de personas de la tercera edad que
viven como okupas en una casa abandonada
en completa vulnerabilidad y a lo largo
de todo el distrito 2 hay un montón de
personas que viven con hambre en pobreza
extrema
padeciendo la injusticia la corrupción
la impunidad el rechazo el desprecio y
si creemos que la única forma de hacer
resolver estos problemas es por la vía
electoral
creemos en una argucia creemos en una
mentira implantada por la política
partidista porque
cuando unos trabajan seis meses en tres
años nosotras las personas lo hacemos
todos los días
a lo largo de la campaña nos dimos a la
tarea de ir documentando todas y cada
una de las problemáticas que fuimos
observando que fuimos escuchando y nos
nos dimos cuenta de un patrón que hay
una infinidad de problemáticas que hay
organizaciones hay colectivos hay
frentes ciudadanos que ya están
trabajando en resolverlas pero no están
conectando con el barrio
quisiera hacer un paréntesis para
platicarles cuál fue el foco que nos
despertó a ilumina para iluminar esta
realidad entre ustedes hay un par de
personas que tengo el honor de que me
hayan acompañado el día de hoy y esas
dos personas
en diferentes etapas de su vida y ver a
diferentes niveles en algún punto
dejaron de creer en la política y en los
procesos electorales
hubo una de ellas en específico que se
juró jamás en su vida volver a
involucrarse en todo lo que tuviera que
ver con política y el día que nos lo
hacen que nos que nos encontramos con
ella y nos dimos unos minutos para
explicarle no la esperanza que nosotros
estamos buscando construir no sólo nos
abre la puerta de su casa nos involucró
con toda su familia
se jugó su credibilidad con sus vecinos
estuvo casi 24 horas padeciendo del
caluroso infierno que fue cuidar las
casillas este primero de julio si no nos
abrió la puerta y su corazón a un
extraño y en una época del país tan
crucial como son las elecciones yo
quisiera si me pueden acompañar con una
ronda de aplausos para ese par de
personas que están aquí el día de hoy
que recuperaron la esperanza en la
política
[Aplausos]
arroz y a coco gracias por acompañarnos
hoy otro aplauso para ellos dos que
están aquí
[Aplausos]
ahora sí una gran duda porque la
ciudadanía no se está enterando de lo
que la palomilla participativa está
construyendo y está logrando en la
ciudad para mí la respuesta es muy obvia
falta de comunicación asertiva del
trabajo que estamos haciendo
un plan estratégico que o falta de un
plan estratégico que nos ayude a
conectar con el barrio agendas de
organizaciones con otras prioridades una
población que no tiene claro qué es lo
que va a lograr involucrándose con
nosotras y nosotros y por ende una
evidente falta de interés y se desconoce
métodos o formas para quienes somos
ciudadanos activos de cómo conectar con
la comunidad con la vecindad y con el
barrio
ahora sí después de hacer un arduo
diagnóstico y poner en orden todo lo
comentado que sigue sigue a ser como
realidad barrial sigue hacer redes de
solidaridad y participación ciudadana y
construir espacios de conocimiento
colectivo
porque ya sabemos cómo perderle el miedo
de tocarle la puerta al desconocido y
que a veces nos cierran la puerta en las
narices
sabemos dónde hay problemas muy
puntuales que organizaciones de la
sociedad civil ya están trabajando y lo
que necesitamos ahora hacer es construir
los espacios para que se encuentren
hace falta pedagogía política un montón
a lo largo de toda la campaña y yo me
fui encontrando con una mayoría de
personas de votantes de ciudadanos que
no saben cuál es la diferencia entre un
diputado y un regidor no saben que hace
un cabildo o qué hace un congreso del
estado y no lo saben no porque no les
interese
no lo saben porque tienen un montón de
condiciones en su vida que tienen que
resolver de manera inmediata y para
resolverlas es elemental organizarnos
entre vecinos y es de suma importancia
saber cuáles son nuestras obligaciones y
nuestros derechos y eso no sólo se hace
perdón eso no solo se dice se hace
de donde sacamos esta información
a lo largo de la campaña que elaboramos
una encuesta todos los días a todos los
que nos encontramos para preguntarles
específicamente cuánto creen ellos que
debería de ser lo justo que debería
ganar su futuro diputado y aprovechamos
en esa encuesta para poner cuestiones de
política básica y nos encontramos con
qué
más de 1500 personas no sabe cuánto gana
un diputado con más de 1300 personas no
sabe qué hace un diputado a pesar de que
vota por él
o con el producto de ese esfuerzo de lo
que le descuentan de su salario de lo
que paga de impuestos le paga su sueldo
a ese funcionario
para hacer para fertilizar este desierto
de conocimiento a veces si vale la pena
voltear hacia atrás
al pasado y rescatar lo que en su época
por ser muy reivindicativo era
considerado radical
reivindicar el empoderamiento y la
gestión colectiva como decía rosa
luxemburgo el deber consiste solamente
en educar a las personas para llevarlas
a su independencia y hacerlas capaces de
tomar el poder por sí mismas
construir una misión histórica en la
conciencia colectiva
las personas necesitan saber quién es
quién y qué hace que las instituciones
para poderse acercar a ellas y resolver
urgente y expeditamente problemas de
carácter público
hace 60 años los black panther parís ya
denunciaban lo que aquí todavía estamos
padeciendo inequidad social y estragos
económicos que tienen como resultado la
pobreza el desempleo la violencia
enfermedades crónico-degenerativas y una
serie de condiciones como consecuencia
de la reducción de los servicios
públicos básicos y el acoso policial
sistematizado
para resolver estos problemas comencé a
ricardo flores magón
hay que revolucionar a las personas
comunes a través de una enseñanza acorde
a las necesidades de la misma comunidad
yo le agregaría como dice malcom x
fortalecer en ese sentido los derechos
civiles y aumentar la conciencia
política
y culminó con esta serie the statements
con lo que ha dicho en varias ocasiones
el consejo indígena de gobierno el
cuidado de la vida de la madre tierra y
de la dignidad es una obligación que
solo podemos responder de forma
colectiva
quisiera acabar esta ponencia con
con una frase muy hermosa que acabe
escucharle hace un par de semanas a
carlos labores que decía sí
un proyecto de barrio un proyecto de
ciudad y un proyecto de país es una
sinfonía y saber que en un momento
específico el tiempo te toca dar una
nota
a mí me tocó ser candidato independiente
y perdí pero nos ganamos a nosotros
mismos cuál es tu nota en esta ciudad
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]